a country
at a crossroads calls for change growing
one week on from elections they say were
rigged
leave they tell their president
this smaller rival crowd cheering for
their man
[Music]
he claims western forces amassing near
the border
talk too of a russian offer of military
support if necessary
but as his own support base wobbling
this top diplomat called for free
elections
condemning police violence against
protesters
i expect a lot of headaches i expect a
lot of difficulties i have
fears i'm a human being but from the
moral point of view
really it was a real relief have you
spoken to
other ambassadors other officials who
feel the same as you i have a feeling
that a lot of persons a lot of
colleagues
they should share my statements
my position but of course they have
fears
they do not want to be
fired
several journalists from state-run
broadcasters
also calling time on the regime my
message
is don't be afraid don't lie to the
people
just try to be honest because you see
through your window that the country
opened uh
ice and right now uh the belarusian
people
are on their way to become democracy and
honest
country with honest elections perhaps so
but the threat of russian involvement
will be worrying the neighbours
the person the protesters think really
won the election
is hiding out here in lithuania after
fleeing belarus
last week svetlana tekonovskaya still
has a few more days to go in quarantine
because of the coronavirus pandemic
but people will be watching her next
steps very closely
even the pope is paying attention to
what's happening
calling for rights to be respected
another sign
of the significance of this moment debra
haynes sky news vilnius